moins de 48 heures après un nouveau
record de décès dans le pays
le président alberto fernandez a décidé
d'opter pour la solution la plus
radicale 1re confinement national de
neuf jours les restrictions de
circulation dans la capitale et sa
grande région décidée par le
gouvernement argentin à la mi avril
n'ont freiné que partiellement la
propagation du virus dans un pays qui
connaît une situation économique
inquiétante
le retour de ces mesures était
particulièrement redouté
soyez moins consciente
je suis très conscient pleinement
conscient que ces restrictions cause des
difficultés dans cette réalité il n'ya
pas d'autre choix que de choisir la
préservation de la vie je ne vais pas
accepter la normalisation de ce nombre
d'infections ou de décès toutes les
données scientifiques indiquent que le
problème est très grave en argentine
aujourd'hui que nous sommes à un niveau
record de contagion et de décès à
compter de samedi minuit le pays entrera
dans un confinement similaire à celui
mis en place au début de l'épidémie
seuls les commerces essentiel resteront
ouverts et toutes les activités en
présentiel seront suspendus excepté les
livraisons à domicile
les argentins ne seront autorisés à
sortir à proximité de leur domicile que
de 6h à 18h alors que le taux
d'occupation en soin intensif et de 72%
dans le pays
alberto fernandez qui parle du pire
moment de la pandémie a malgré tout tenu
à rassurer sa population et annoncé une
mise à disposition plus importante de
vaccins pour l'heure seulement 18 pour
cent des 45 millions d'argentins ont
reçu une première dose